bene i ragazzi minuti questo nuovissimo
video che sono fa vj oggi siamo tornati
con un nuovo video dove vi racconto una
cosina allora questa cosa molto
importante che non è successa nella vita
l'avevo già detto perché avevo fatto
un'intervista a riguardo però volevo
parlare di questo argomento ora che ho
iniziato a fare i video del genere
quindi trattarlo in maniera un po più
specifica ho sofferto di depressione
bene era novembre del
2020 ok a novembre del 2020
sono caduti nei pressioni per svariati
motivi in realtà ma non ce n'era uno in
particolare era proprio questo il
discorso so che ha molti succede quando
è successo perché io comunque allora
finché non non ti succede di avere di
soffrire di depressione di avere un
attacco di panico cosa del genere vedi
sempre questa cosa la vedi con occhi
tipo mammamia poverino mi dispiace
chissà che cosa vuol dire cioè tutti
vedi i propri estraneo a questa cosa qua
chi ne parla dice mamma mia che roba
brutta mi dispiace non capisci realmente
perchè dici ma meno male che io non ho
questa cosa e poi da un giorno all'altro
incredibilmente succede a me ok e quindi
da esterno che vedevo sempre questa
situazione dicevo che mi dispiace soffri
di ansia depressione per questo mi
dispiace ma mi è arrivata a me in dritta
in faccia ha detto ah ecco cosa
significa
beh la mer bella merde iniziati a
novembre 2020 e si è conclusa più o meno
più o meno ad aprile del 2021 quindi è
durata all'incirca
siluro sei mesi più o meno sei mesi
tosti molto tosti perché io ho iniziato
a non dormire
o mangiare a piangere ho avuto ho avuto
proprio un momento un po di merda che
non era mai successo per delle
motivazioni che non esistono cioè
sostanzialmente per delle motivazioni
che mi sono creato da un giorno
all'altro c'è un articolo che parla di
questo magari se mi ricordo ma non mi
ricordano mai però lascio nella
descrizione magari si si legge perché
poi molti mi avevate scritto l'anno
scorso quando si parlava di questo
ringrazio
insomma spiegavo che la mia ansia non
era portato la mia depressione ansia
tutto insieme non erano portate da un
motivo ma da una serie di piccole
motivazioni stupide io avevo paura di
fare qualsiasi cosa sostanzialmente
qualsiasi perché avevo paura delle
ripercussioni che questa cosa potesse
avere su di me ma di che tipo di tipo
stupido nel senso che avevo paura ad
uscire e
io faccio sempre questo esempio perché
una delle mie prime paure e stata questa
avevo paura di uscire e di buttare
qualcosa in un cestino per paura che
quella cosa accadesse fuori dal cestino
e siccome mi conosce un sacco di gente
fuori ma ho paura che la gente mi
prendesse come uno inquina ok sembra una
cazzata ma io vi giuro che o suo figlio
aveva sofferto di ansia per motivi
stupidi ora questa era per farvi un
esempio non è che mi è durata tanto non
è che non uscivo per questo era per
farvi un esempio delle motivazioni che
di base sono stupide le motivazioni per
le quali sono andato in depressione
erano tantissime ok non ce n'era una
c'erano un milione che una volta non
erano un problema sono sempre state ma
una volta non lo erano improvvisamente
sono diventate un problema
ok improvvisamente sono andate un
problema grosso che non mi faceva
dormire la notte ok e non nelle sale in
casa e tutte perché molte soltanto sono
stupidissime e altre sono comunque
diciamo tutte legate al fatto che sono
un personaggio pubblico quindi che
quello che io faccio purtroppo a una
risonanza maggiore che se lo fa qualcun
altro ok perché io sono io e quindi se
io faccio pp su un muro
esco sul giornale che ho fatto la pipì
sul muro se tu fai arrivi sul muro
massimo becchi il passante che fa è non
fa la pipì sui muri e non diciamo che
insomma tutti i problemi erano derivati
dal fatto che di essere un personaggio
pubblico e quindi ho smesso di espormi
ma ma non d
di ideologie più di tutto c'è proprio
non rimane anche nei messaggi di
whatsapp ai miei amici amici proprio
amici stretti non mandava messaggi
perché ho paura che for vs raw le mie
pazzia ero diventato pazzo ma pazzo
non dormivo non mangiavo bruttissimo e
stato orribile mi ha salvato la vita in
quel caso
fare intraprendere un percorso del quale
non parlerò nello specifico perché sennò
viene fuori un video chilometrico però
sostanzialmente il mio manager
il mio allora manager lorenzo mia
consigli parlava da tempo di questo
seminario chiamano seminario che ti
aiuta insomma a instradare la tua vita
questo seminario avrei dovuto farlo
senza avere quei problemi li addirittura
c'è perché lo puoi fare sia che tu abbia
che stia vivendo momento brutto sia che
tu non lo stia vivendo infatti volevo
andarci da sempre ma non ho mai avuto il
tempo li ho avuto proprio necessità di
farlo perché stavo sotto un ponte c'è
proprio mentalmente stato messo male e
quindi ho detto devo velocizzare devo
fare questa cosa
e sono andato a fare questo seminario
che si chiama hoffman
non vi parlerò nello specifico perché
veramente ci sarebbero mille video da
fare per raccontarvi bene l'esperienza
dell'oman
sostanzialmente comunque un seminario
intensivo dove lavori una settimana
intera su te stesso giorno e notte c'era
niente tutti svegli lavori su te stesso
tutto il giorno e poi vai a dormire il
giorno dopo uguale quindi ti concentri
su te stesso
ne sono uscito nuovo o distrutto la mia
ansia e le mie paure di quel periodo che
sono durate sei mesi ho iniziato a
dormire mangiare mi ha salvato perché
non veramente stavo messo veramente di
merda non vi sto a dire bene quindi che
cosa succede in che cosa consiste però
sostanzialmente ci sono delle pratiche
traversa attraverso anche la meditazione
che li aiutano io da lì ho iniziato a
vivere ea star bene con la
consapevolezza però che queste
problematiche esistono perché l'ho
vissuto sulla mia pelle ed è stato molto
brutto e stato molto brutto perché
sentirne sempre parlare ma non viverle
mai di persona è un conto quando poi ci
sei di mezzo anche tu sono un altro paio
di maniche quindi è stato proprio un
periodo in cui mi sono reso conto che
c'è tanta gente che al giorno d'oggi
lotta lotta per star bene perché magari
non stanno bene con se stessi con quello
che vivono
con quello che hanno intorno intendo e
quindi devono combattere questo questo
questa cosa se sono stati ma e se stanno
male come sono sono stato io
insomma adesso ho un tipo di sensibilità
diversa nei confronti di chi magari
soffre di depressione eccetera
si combatte la depressione si può uscire
dalla depressione
e
poi c'erano un miliardo di discorsi
stupidi che i tempi mi facevano anche
magari persone a me vicine della serie a
ma con quella bella vita che fai col
lavoro che ti piace cui guadagni che
c'hai che cazzo c'hai da
vuol dire non vuol dire
niente questo non vuol dire niente
perché uno può essere depresso anche se
a tutto apparentemente tutto dalla vita
non c'entrano nulla perché ognuno vive
l'asso le sue battaglie ogni persona che
incontrato vive le sue battaglie vanno
anche lo sapete è anche per questo che
tra l'altro dico che i soldi non fanno
la felicità perché
ci sono tantissime cose
da tantissime cose nella vita che
possono influire
sulla persona sulla singola persona
quindi non sa di niente comunque la cosa
migliore che ho fatto nel periodo in cui
sono stato male che continuava a stare
male ma ho cercato di circondarmi di
persone che mi volevano bene questa cosa
mi ha aiutato tantissimo mi ha aiutato
tantissimo e quindi ricordatevi non
siete soli cercate sempre
di confidarvi insomma di parlare dei
problemi con qualcuno perché questa cosa
aiuta moltissimo il cambiamento il
cambiamento però deve partire sempre da
voi stessi questo questo sempre magari
sono cose scontate ma è giusto dirle
perché avendole vissute sono proprio le
cose giuste che ho fatto e che mi hanno
aiutato fatemi sapere ragazzi cosa ne
pensate nei commenti
sapete qualcosa da condividere
io cerco di leggervi come sempre tutti
anche i dm qua su youtube iscrivetevi al
canale lasciate un commento mi piace
ragazzi e noi come sempre chiediamo a un
prossimo video bella ragazzi
[Musica]